[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque nouvel attentat ravive sa douleur
aziza a perdu son fils l'année dernière
il avait 22 ans
[Musique]
ça me venait de trouver un poste de
gardien d'immeuble à sevran
c'est justement sur son lieu de travail
qu il s'est radicalisé en quatre mois
auprès d'un collègue excités ils
voulaient plus il voulait plus regardée
dans les yeux sa chef de site
sami annonce ensuite à sa famille qu'il
part faire le pèlerinage à la mecque
c'est en fait en syrie qu'il se rend un
an plus tard il meurt dans un accident
de voiture
je sais que c'est marié je sais que j'ai
une petite fille d'abord et quand il est
décédé j'ai on a juste envoyé un
certificat de décès de d'âge
aziza décide alors de s'investir elle
rejoint la brigade des mers une
association de parents inquiets de la
montée de la radicalisation dans les
quartiers notre but c'est de faire de la
prévention pour empêcher les gens de
partir si on en sort un déçu par
l'impuissance de l'état
aziza lutte aujourd'hui contre le
phénomène qui lui a volé son fils
bonjour alors je me présente la diarrhée
magna alors je vais vous dire pourquoi
j'ai créé cette association qui
s'appelle la brigade des mers alors j'ai
plusieurs constats mais bon on peut vous
dire au moins deux grands constats il ya
quelques années je suis rentrée des
vacances je venais d'algérie et dans
l'avion j'ai fait connaissance d'une
maman qui habite pas loin de ma ville de
sevran
on en parle un petit peu du terrorisme
en algérie
oui on n'avait qu'une avant de
terrorisme en algérie je suis originaire
d'algérie et ce qui m'avait choqué quand
d'arriver à l'aéroport
cette maman à roissy sort un foulard se
voile la tête
il sort une grande robe je lui pose la
question mais qu'est ce que vous faites
a mis tout simplement je ne peux pas
rentrer dans mon quartier aujourd'hui
comme ça je suis dit mais vous rendez
compte on vient d'algérie un pays qui a
eu neuf ans de guerre civile
vous avez dit on est en france et vous
voiler j'ai été choqué
on y constate deuxième constat un jour
mon fils rentre en courant sonne à la
porte et me dit maman maman s'il te
plaît tu peux retirer le sapin de noël
je peux le mettre de côté parce que tous
les copains sont en train de me dire que
ta maman c'est une est criante c'est pas
une bonne musulmane et que le père noël
n'existe pas monfils avait 8 ans à
l'époque je descends vers les jeunes
savoir où était le problème parce que
c'était le sapin de noël qui dérangeait
est ce que c'était les guirlandes
c'était les boules de noël qui c'est
quoi qui est dérangé dire non quand on
est un bon musulman doit dire la vérité
à ses enfants
vous êtes en train de mentir à vos
enfants vous êtes confins de leur dire
c'est en train de fêter noël
deuxième constat est malheureusement
après en 2005 pour ceux qui s'en
souviennent on a eu les émeutes des
banlieues
et oui les émeutes des banlieues en 2005
alors que ce qu'on nous a proposé
l'état fait appel à qui au lieu de faire
appel aux éducateurs aux professionnels
social au médiateur maintenant on fait
appel à qui au grand frère
alors moi je n'avais pas de grand frère
j'étais une femme seule avec quatre
enfants
déjà j'étais exclue j'avais l'impression
qu'on m'avait retiré l'autorité
parentale
chaque fois qu'un homme est un problème
on me disait d'aller voir les grands
frères alors moi je suis je suis
problème social et je me suis dit il
faut qu'on fasse quelque chose alors je
trouve un poste comme médiatrice
scolaire dans un collège zep dans la
ville de sevran
mon premier jour j'attends le principal
est dans le couloir j'aperçois une
personne qui s'adresse à un élève et qui
lui pose cette question et comme ça
serait qui hier je ne t'ai pas vu à la
mosquée je regarde je n'ai pas osé
intervenir parce que c'est mon premier
jour de travail
le principal me reçoit bonjour bonjour
est ce jeune homme qui était qui avait
dit à cet élève je ne connaissais la
fatigue ce n'est pas dû à la mosquée est
rentré dans le bureau et s'assied à côté
de moi je pensais que c'était un élève
de 3e
je lui pose la question je l'interface
jeudi me rendais compte on est dans l
éducation nationale
on est dans un pays laïc comment se
fait-il que vous dites à un enfant je ne
t'ai pas vu à la mosquée le principal
midi mais écoutez madame et maintenant
heureusement que j'ai ce genre de
personnel dans mon établissement
je n'aurais pas ce genre de personnel
dans men tablissements vous rendez
compte le collège serait à feu et à sang
du coup je décide de faire la brigade
des mers en fin de compte pourquoi cette
façon ce qu'en tant que travail social
il y avait trop de barrières on nous
forme justement avec barrière barrière
ne pas dire ne pas faire à remplir des
documents administratifs
alors il fallait que je retire toutes
ces barrières qui m'ont empêché de voir
ce qui ce qui s'est passé je me suis
souvent posé la question je me suis posé
la question en tant que femme et en tant
que mère je suis posé la question est ce
que ce sont nous les femmes qui avant
les maires qui avons mal transmis
l'éducation de nos enfants
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je fais cette
association et en faisant la brigade des
mers je rentre bien sûr j'avais deux
casquettes j'étais un travail social et
j'étais la présidente de l'association
la brigade des mers ça m'a permis
justement de faire un bon travail sur le
terrain parce que c'était quoi vu qu'on
nous avait retiré l'autorité parentale
pour moi les grands frères s'étaient
robe se rapproprier l'autorité parentale
et ramené au quartier dans les coeurs et
ramener la république dans les coeurs
des quartiers c'est ça la brigade des
mers c'était ça mon but c'est que toutes
les femmes que toutes les mères que tous
les parents sera propre risque on leur
avait de retirer l'autorité parentale et
on l'avait donné au grand frère ensuite
on a de grands projets je reviens de
super dont la brigade des mers on à
l'école des mères et de la république et
les ponts de la connaissance l'école des
mères et de la république c'est sur
quatre modules alors on à la philo
pourquoi la philo parce que ça permet de
la critique ce que c'est ça le problème
aussi c'est dur de dire les choses de
les nommer alors moi j'ose dire les
choses je les nomme c'est pas facile je
le fais et aussi les points de la
connaissance pourquoi parce que pour moi
je me dis c'est plus facile de faire des
pompes que des murs parce que je me suis
rendu compte dans constat aussi qui
avait deux choses il y avait des
préjugés des deux côtés on nous a
toujours dit à la base ce sont les
méchants
là-bas ce sont les racistes et de
l'autre côté on leur a dit là-bas ce
sont les voyous du coup il y avait des
préjugés des deux côtés et c'est pour ça
que avec la brigade des mers on a été au
plus long là était de l'autre côté on a
pris le rer
on a été chercher les gens de paris
voilà on a réduit les parisiens
effectivement la radicalisation ne
concerne pas que les gens
lieu c'est faux je peux vous dire que ça
touche tout le monde nous sommes tous
concernés
quel que soit notre statut social quel
que soit notre religion ou pas nous
sommes tous concernés du phénomène
malheureusement qui aujourd'hui occupent
nos quartiers aujourd'hui je peux vous
dire que dans les quartiers nous sommes
moi je dis souvent ça n'engage que moi
ce que je dis je dis souvent que les
quartiers sont islamisée et c'est pour
ça que nous les maires que nous les
femmes on se bat pour à pour être n'est
pas pour être liée pour la liberté on se
bat pour rester livre parce qu'en 2016
en france ce vous rendez compte on est
censé être libre et aujourd'hui on
revient en arrière alors le but de la
brigade des mers c'est se réapproprier
les quartiers occuper l'espace public et
surtout surtout récupérer ce qui nous
appartient de plus cher ce sont nos
enfants
et c'est pour ça dans ces deux projets
on essaye de les mettre en place parce
que je vous dis la vérité c'est pas
facile faire une école des mères et de
la république c'est pas facile il faut
faut les moyens il faut on a les
bénévoles et tout ça mais c'est pas
évident surtout particulièrement là où
je viens du 93 c'est très très dur et
aujourd'hui moi j'y crois
pourquoi j'y crois parce que je me dis
que une maman qu'elle est la maman
d'entre vous le parent même les papas
parce qu'à la brigade des mers ont là
aussi des papin quel est le parent qui
n'a pas envoyé un texto à son fait son
goût disant t'es où t'es où théo la
réponse est quoi t'inquiète pas qu'elle
s'inquiète une fois mon fils et il veut
rentrer de la meinau m'a dit maman dans
un mois tu m'as envoyé 150 t ou t'es où
t'es où t'es où
et lui il a répondu 150 watts en
quelques québec mtq est imaginé capter
ou thé ou quand vous allez quatre
enfants bref d'additionner et on a des
témoins je suis et rien que pour ça on
s'est dit on peut être nous on peut être
d'accord on ne peut être d'accord ou pas
d'accord sur beaucoup de choses mais il
ya une chose au monde voilà c'est quoi
qui nous rassemblent à brigade des mers
la brigade des mers on a de tout on a
des dates et des musulmans des juifs on
a de tout ça mais c'est quoi qui nous
rassemble je vais vous dire l'amour de
nos enfants et rien que pour ça on est
obligé de se battre tous ensemble mais
tous tous tous tous ensemble ce que vous
avez vu tout à l'heure dans le reportage
serons nous à montré aziza je peux vous
dire que malheureusement on a de plus en
plus de mamans qui viennent nous voir
parce qu'elles ont pas
or et comme vous savez je dis souvent
quand vous avez un enfant en échec
scolaire
vous allez voir un prof ou un enseignant
qui va vous aider quand vous êtes
victime de vol ou autre vous allez au
commissariat mais quand vous avez un
enfant de 14 ans 15 ans qui se
radicalise vous allez voir qui c'est ça
le problème et c'est pour ça qu'on a
nous cette brigade des mers pour donner
cet espace au pouvoir alerter si on fait
rien aujourd'hui
dans quelques années on va regretter
parce que vous savez j'avais discuté
avec deux ou trois personnes hier à
avignon une 18 mai chez nous c'est pas
comme ça de chez nous il ya dix ans
c'était comme ça alors si vous faites
rien dans quelques années ça va devenir
comme chez nous alors c'est maintenant
qu'il faut se réveiller et tous ensemble
et moi je ne sais pas s'il ya des
politiques parmi nous mais je veux dire
aujourd'hui ne faut pas avoir peur de
nommer les choses parce qu'aujourd'hui
il ya un problème il existe il est là il
faut qu'on fasse ensemble et pas les uns
contre les autres
alors moi je vous dire que cette
association me tient à coeur pourquoi
parce que mon devoir en tant que
citoyenne française
je pense que je dois l'accomplir
pourquoi parce que souvent les jeunes me
disent mais qu'est ce que vous faites
pour nous et c'est vrai que ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui on va faire pour le
pour nos enfants pour l'avenir de la
france
moi j'ai vécu le terrorisme en algérie
et je peux vous dire j'ai peur pour la
france j'ai peur pour mon pays j'ai peur
pour mes enfants j'ai peur pour vous
j'ai peur pour tout le monde alors on
doit alors moi je lui dis alors qu'il
faut les rejoindre la brigade des mers
vous pouvez venir vous battre avec nous
vous pouvez venir voilà à voir qu'est ce
qui se passe la réalité du terrain
et puis faut arrêter de dire s'il vous
plaît non pas stigmatiser c'est pas vrai
c'est une minorité
non je peux vous dire que c'est une
réalité ensemble sûr qu'on peut faire
quelque chose pour sauver nos enfants et
pour sauver la france
merci
[Applaudissements]